What's up guys we're Pongfinity!
It's minus 20 celsius here in Finland
so we thought it's a perfect weather to play outside.
So let's make an ice table!
It's gonna be a mystery howwell we can play on this.
So, what's the plan?
So first we'll take this snowout of here.
Then we're gonna measure the table.
Take the snow away from the edges.
Then put some water on it.
Let it freeze.
Yeah it shouldbe fine.
Lets crack it on!
Yeah!
We have this old-fashioned measure here.
152.
I think we are ready to play.
Otto I have an idea.
Go stand on it.
Yeah.
Yes, thanks!
If someone was to take this out of context...
Normal day in Finland!
Recently I've found myself jumping awfully a lot.
Sensei says...
Almost perfect!
I think we're ready with that!
What are you laughing at?
Can i touchit?
No.
This one, it almost looks like a tooth!
It's like a tooth sticking out!
Chop chop chop chop..
This is quite satisfying.
It's impressive!
Nice table!
After two hours.
Just to make surethere isn't any weird bounces
which there probably will be but trying tominimize those.
This side is a bit more up.
Yeah I think that's good enough.
Lets goto the lake!
We're gonna get some water.
We have to break the ice to get some water.
What is a frozen lake's worst nightmare?
Sensei with an axe!
Emil I have a question for you.
What's Miikka's worst nightmare?
Oooh I'm through!
Water, there's water!
It's frozen again.
Noooo.
Finnish winter, a lot of snow,beautiful sunshine.
What could be better?
It already froze!
There's like a five centimeter thing
where you can go around the net here.
This is again one of those projects that it's really interesting
like you don't know what's going to happen
ordoes it even work so it's quite cool!
Yeah I mean this looks so cool!
It almost feelslike you would immediately want to try it
but we have to wait for tomorrow!
Feeling quite hard already.
Look at that surface!
It'spretty cool!
Yeah more water!
Oooooh it's getting smooth!
The table must be pretty cold.
We're off to the frozen lake.
Now that's abucket!
It's not gonna break that's for sure!
Looking forward to tomorrow!
Beautifulmorning.
Morning coffee by the fireplace, what could be better.
So, day two, it's -17 degreestoday.
It should be rock solid.
If I go stand there..
It can take the weight of an Emil.
Emil solid!
So 250 kilos.
So if it takes Emil's weight it should be able to take the table tennis balls weight.
Yeah I would think that.
The most important thing.
The Pongfinity logo!
It's a rough estimateof our logo.
So shall we do the edges?
Yeah this is pretty much a must do because otherwise
it's very difficult to see the lines on camera.
There!
The moment of truth.
Drop it Miikka, drop the ball!
Has all the effort been for nothing.
Oh it does! Very good.
It's a bit random.
It bounces, that's very good!
The black ball is quitecool!
Shall we do it?
Yeah.
Okay, are you ready?
I am!
Sidespin!
That was a good serve.
Nice one!
Hello!
Was it around the net?
It was!
Nice rally!
Whoa what a spin!
Backspin.
Alright so this was quite an arctic idea.
Well yes it was!
Nice one Emil!
But it alsoworked out really well.
Yeah it was fine.
Better than i expected.
Yeah thanks for watching and until next time!
Straight onto the lens..